i would i would love to like be able to
turn on my lucid dreams if if i if i had
that [ __ ] power i'd be like
like that that is literally so it's not
normal for you to be aware you're in a
dream no
i didn't know that that's not normal are
you always aware yeah like most of the
time i'd say like 80 of the time i know
i'm in a dream oh my god are you serious
you're there you're that kid at school
that aces the test without studying
why was decision because
that's always because he knows he's in a
dream yeah but he can't control it yeah
i can't control it
that's like that's like getting the the
becoming a lucid dreamer without having
the fun part of being a lucid dreamer
it's weird because like i can i'm aware
i'm in a dream and i know that i can
like
i can want things i know i feel that i
want the thing in the dream yeah but it
doesn't always happen like i don't know
how that have you ever like had a
superpower when you're like in a dream
yeah
yeah many times well define superpower
but then i die normally
it's too much power to handle
for one minute literally like in your
own mind you're playing on hard mode i
didn't realize it was that possible it's
all these superpowers i guess i'll die
i'm trying to think he's like yeah i
always know
some like i said always some i'd say 80
of the time i'm i'm i feel that
halfway through or some period in the
dream i know that i'm dreaming because
things don't add up in my head when i'm
in the dream yeah even it's weeks i feel
like i'm conscious in the dream so i
know what's happening and i know that
some things don't add up yeah and i'm
aware that i have the knowledge from my
normal human life right and i can i have
that instead dream so like if somebody
[ __ ] teleports behind me at some
point after that happens x amount of
times or something i'm aware then that
this is now not possible
yeah when i die and i just point this is
recent mechanics i have so much in your
dream what is this no no no it doesn't
happen often but when it has happened
like if i die but i'm still dreaming
yeah i immediately know
that now i'm in a dream yeah because i
died because she died yeah and also
generally you can't reset really you
know what's weird as well
i don't know if this is a strange thing
but when i'm in danger yeah that's
normally a good way that i know because
i'm rarely in life am i ever in danger
in like weird situations right so being
in danger is like not a normal emotion i
ever feel
yeah i mean so when i end up coming
across it in the dream like if
somebody's chasing me that's normally
like a one really weird way that i get
like in tune with the fact that i'm in a
dream i yeah cause i also like very
rarely dream for one but even more rare
is for me to get nightmares
i see all of mine like nearly nightmares
i want to say like again eighty percent
probably in the background
how do you sleep at night i don't mind
okay this is the thing right when
something bad's happening to me in a
dream i cause again i know it's a dream
i feel these emotions towards it but
then i also because again i'm aware it's
a dream i have this weird sense of like
well let's just see what could happen
because i don't feel like it has any
input
on my actual emotions i'm aware that it
isn't is this strange is this normal i
mean i feel like if you have nightmares
that often yeah and uh that's the thing
i don't wake up from a nightmare being
like like in the movies well oh that's
why i always found that [ __ ] so dumb
because we can find a nightmare
bad happens to me what no i wake up from
a nightmare i'm like oh [ __ ] my phone
no i wake up and like
if it's like really bad nightmares which
i've had every now and then like i wake
up in an actual sweat i've had like my
entire life in every single aspect like
ruined in dreams before
and like waking up like that's good
i'm feeling better now
because because when i wake up i feel
much better because i'm like i'll get it
no no go because i've had i've had
nightmares where something was like bad
has happened
and then you wake up and you just have
like this instant sigh of relief where
you're like yeah oh my god thank [ __ ] i
thought my life was like ruined yeah and
like it's it's going it's great it's
[ __ ] great i can't be in this house
i'm not in jail with my mom like i'm i'm
i find like so many charging cables
i think i've had like a dream where i've
like literally had to tell my mom i'm
about to go to jail
seeing her cry and break down i was just
like that was cruel it was just like the
one i wake up and i'm just like why does
my mind do this to me like that was like
the most heartbreaking feeling i've had
which is telling my mom i'm about to go
to jail and i remember her [ __ ]
crying and breaking down god me feeling
like a like a vegas really like the
worst [ __ ] human in the world i wake
up and i'm just like i've never loved my
life more than i have now i've never
felt more fulfilled i've never had that
so you so people in your world have like
really depth emotion emotional abilities
yeah yeah yeah yeah see that's weird
because in mine it's like i'm the only
person who is aware of like how emotions
work and everyone else seems to be like
robotic
so everyone's like an npc
kind of yeah like because when i the the
depth isn't there so like even when my
parents are in the dream the reason
again it's another weird thing i think
it gives it away though
the thing that normally makes me no not
enough world building yeah
generally this is another thing where it
wakes me like where i feel like i become
again in tune into the dream that i know
it's a dream is when people aren't
acting the way i i my brain knows they
are but it's weird right because my
brain is the one making this yeah so why
does my brain make the people like this
but then in the dream my brain also
it's like i'm playing checkers against
myself and i'm like fantastic move
connor you figured out the plan you know
what i mean it's like what is happening
in my brain
even when you sleep you try to beat
yourself
you're literally creating a you're
literally creating a game for you to
beat while you sleep like what is
happening the absolute stage
absolutely
like makes so much sense because i swear
every one of my dreams is like a [ __ ]
easter guy to me right
i literally get transported into my own
[ __ ] story in my own [ __ ] world
yeah there's depth in the world building
there there's like some high concept
[ __ ] dreams that i remember like
characters actually
characters in my dream actually act like
characters in real life
finally i can self-insult which is like
which is like sometimes when i wake up
and someone's like done like i remember
like one time i had a dream where sydney
murdered my family
and i remember waking up i remember
waking up just as like i like found her
i don't wait i woke up and i turned to
her with such [ __ ] anger i'll be like
you [ __ ] i can't believe you did that
to my mom and dad
how dare you you better have a good
reason
i was about we were about to go to trial
i will see you in court
because like at the time like the
emotions felt so the emotions felt so
real to me that i i don't know like
sometimes when i woke when i wake up and
the dream isn't resolved i still have
like those emotions fresh in my body
refresh my mind like it's like hard to
like sometimes get rid of it it's like
it's like those stereotypical like you
know the girlfriend dreams about the
boyfriend cheating the girlfriend's
dream wakes up soon that's the boyfriend
it's like what the [ __ ] who is she
it's like what the [ __ ]
it's the exact same
i've never understood that but now i do
i've never spoken about my dreams in
depth it's the first time thinking like
oh yeah maybe my dreams are weird maybe
i'm the weirder i i thought i didn't
remember much of my dreams but now that
now that i'm thinking about it maybe i
do just remember a lot of because i
don't dream often but when i do dream
it's like an event for me you know it's
it's
it's it's literally like watching a film
it's great it's great this one's going
into the memory bank also sometimes i
have dreams that i at least i can only
remember
that are very brief dreams like
30 seconds of a dream that i can
remember and i've woken up yeah the
latest one i remembered i was cooking me
i don't remember why yeah i didn't know
i was in that dream
i just woke up and i was probably the
thing that gave me food poisoning i
don't know
i remember i was cooking meat and uh
poisoning your dreams
that's another thing i don't think i
ever get sick in my dreams from all the
ones i've remembered i don't think i've
ever gotten ill in a dream i don't think
i've ever well i mean you're you've gone
one step above and you just straight up
dying
i never die from like it's never like a
dream of me on the bed and i'm like
like it's yeah i'm always getting
stabbed getting thrown getting shot like
i mean in your dream you're
you should be in like your peak
performance like
your peak formula i think it'll be
pretty sad if your imagination is just
like now you're you're a frail
[ __ ] you're a frail [ __ ]
in your dreams now you can't fly how
many times would you like to die but
it's really exciting i've had dreams
that other people have been sick in them
and i've been around just like the whole
dream has been around this person who's
progressively getting more ill yeah and
that was those dreams are really
depressing yeah because even though
again i'm aware i'm in a dream i can't
do anything to help them i feel like but
i don't and i still feel sad because
seeing this dream sad version that i've
made up that i'm getting more dead is
really saddening this is so strange this
is really bizarre i i think one of this
is why inception was so good i think one
of the weirdest i think one of the
weirdest dreams i had which actually
would be like a cool concept is i
remember i remember one time i like i i
remember one time i woke up and i for
some reason i was just i knew i was like
the second coming of christ
like i i'm like i knew i knew i was the
chosen one i knew i was the messiah
right i knew i was the messiah but the
problem is right so so i think that's
called the sigma male grant
so the problem is right the problem is i
knew i was the messiah yeah but for the
life of me i could not prove it to the
world right so so like so like i would
try to go outside every crazy guy
so i would go out and i would like
perform miracles i would i would go out
and i would like walk on water and [ __ ]
like this and then and i remember i
would be like guys i am the messiah and
everyone be like that's magic trick
that's where where's the mirrors at
where's the mirror
and it was just it was just me
progressively getting more more and more
more angry i think i like even [ __ ]
went on joe rogan at one point in this
stream right three like jesus christ
i am jesus christ he goes proves it and
i remember like i turned the frogs right
now i remember i took my hand out and i
like i just like made fire in my hand
and he's like that's not impressive i've
i've seen magicians do that
do something real
do a real miracle so all i'm hearing is
the the dream god wasn't actually about
you becoming a god it was that you're
furious with the current state of magic
catching up to real life because it was
it was me thinking if there was an
actual messiah that got born into our
world
how would they go about proving it
what would like what would they be
that was that was just like it is very
hard in the modern era okay yeah special
effects yeah now that you say that
someone's going to make a [ __ ] jesus
guy
literally take that concept so i
remember jesus
i was like that's a really cool concept
i'm i'm glad my that was a cool concept
copy right there right now yeah now that
i've said it someone someone can go
write a story but i don't [ __ ] know